>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> James Gleick: And so now,
I'd to introduce James Gleick.
We've both been in the science
writing game for quite a while.
And I don't think we met
before today although,
we may have passed each other
on 246 Street as I was walking
to Horace Mann and he
was walking to Riverdale
which are two neighboring
fierce competitor.
We hate everybody at
Riverdale kinds of place,
you know, high schools, anyway.
>> James Gleick: All right,
that's your-- is that a surprise?
>> Joe Palca: That's the surprise.
>> James Gleick: OK.
>> Joe Palca: Jim was
born in the US--
>> James Gleick: And we
haven't change a bit?
>> Joe Palca: Ah, good.
Oh, we should make for that.
Jim was born in 19-- arrived in
New York at 1954 when he was born.
I arrived there a year earlier.
He graduated from Harvard
College in 1976.
He founded the-- He
founded Metropolis,
an alternative weekly
newspaper in Minneapolis, right?
>> James Gleick: Yeah.
>> Joe Palca: Then he worked for
the New York Times as an editor
and reporter for 10 years and
he became a fantastic author.
His first book, "Chaos"
was a National Book Award
and Pulitzer Prize finalist
and a huge best seller.
He was also the author
of "The Information:
A History, A Theory, A Flood."
And his other books include the
best selling biographies, "Genius:
The Life and Science of Richard
Feynman" and "Isaac Newton."
And believe me, it's hard to top
Richard Feynman in his own writing,
so it's quite a note to be
doing that, as well as "Faster,"
and "What Just Happened."
They've been translated
into 30 languages.
And for some years, he has written--
he wrote the Fast-Forward
column in the New York Times.
And today, we'll be talking about
his new book, "Time Travel."
And he'll be available downstairs.
I guess you guys know where
that is now but it's way
down after the sign-- after the
session to sign book if you want.
And I thought where like,
where I'd start is, you know,
I kind of wondered, you've been
writing about, thinking about,
talking about I presumed time
for quite a long, long
time in your life.
And I was wondering, you know,
when that started and then I came
across the answer on a footnote
on the bottom of page 244--
>> James Gleick: Oh no.
>> Joe Palca: -- of the book.
I think this was just a test
to see if I really read it.
But, you're talking again is
what is time is the question
and the book grapples with that
in many ways which we'll back--
we'll go back and describe.
But one of the answers,
Samuel Johnson said
"the measure of duration."
And then Jim writes, "And duration?
Continuance, length of time.
A 1960 children's book,
trimmed the definition
to a single word: Time Is When."
Oh, that's interesting but
there's a little asterisk there.
And I look and the
asterisk says, "Beth Gleick,
Time Is When (Chicago:
Rand McNally, 1960).
The present author's mother."
[ Laughter ]
So I figured you came by this
interest honestly as they say.
>> James Gleick: Well, I should
recommend "Time Is When" now.
I should fix that.
1960, so I was 6 year old.
>> Joe Palca: Yes.
>> James Gleick: And, yes, my mother
wrote a children's book called
"Time Is When."
It was meant to explain to children
what time is and as I remember,
there is-- there are days, there
are hours, there are minutes,
what if you're a kid, what
can you do in a minute and--
but I didn't really make a
direct connection in my mind
between that book, and
the "Time Travel" book.
It's just-- It did come to me and
I did put that in the footnote.
>> Joe Palca: OK.
I was only trying to make the
point that this has been an--
a theme we could trace
back to your early days.
>> James Gleick: I've written
about time in time, you know--
well, you can't write about
anything without writing about time.
You can-- certainly can write about
science without writing about time
so there are bits about time
in probably all my books.
But "Time Travel" sort of
came out of the blue for me.
I mean, it's not like
I was working up to it.
It's not like I ever-- I thought
I would get around to that.
It was more of a sudden-- there
was a sudden thing that I realized
that made me think,
there was a book here.
>> Joe Palca: And?
>> James Gleick: And so, I
should say what that is, it was--
it's sort of the starting
point of the book.
It was the discovery-- the discovery
that the idea of time travel
in our culture didn't start
until H.G. Wells wrote
"The Time Machine" in 1895.
>> Joe Palca: I read that
and I'm stunned but--
>> James Gleick: I'm-- And I'm glad
you're stunned because I was stunned
and I think-- and a lot of people,
I think maybe there are people
in the audience right now who are
saying, "No that can't be true."
I mean, there are.
I hope you're saying, "That
can't possibly be true,"
because it feels weird.
I mean, it feels-- it feels
as though time travel
is such a natural idea.
It's such an obvious
fantasy to have.
Doesn't everybody think at one
time or another in our lives,
what if I could get into a machine
or walk through a magic door,
or just wake up and see what the
future would be like, or go back
and meet somebody famous
in the past?
Or, you know, we've seen all of
the fantasies working themselves
out in popular culture,
you know, meet your parents
when they were teenagers.
People really didn't
have this fantasy
and so I thought maybe it
would be worth exploring why
that hadn't happen before and what
kind of change was taking place
in the way people were
thinking about time
to make this a natural
kind of entertainment?
>> Joe Palca: Yeah.
And now, I'm wondering
was "Connecticut Yankee
in King Arthur's Court"
prior to that
but that was like it
was an accident?
>> James Gleick: It was prior.
And yeah, that's a good point.
It was about four or
five years before.
You-- Do you all remember
"Connecticut Yankee
in King Arthur's Court," our
hero who I think is the narrator
of the book-- is he the narrator?
>> Joe Palca: I guess I remember.
He--
>> James Gleick: His method of time
travel, that was not a machine,
it's-- he gets conked on the head
and then he wakes up and he's
in a field and he discovers--
and I love this bit of dialogue,
it's Mark Twain bit of
dialogue, there's a, you know,
knight on a horse, and our
guide, he's an engineer wakes up
and he says, he points to
the town, down, you know,
off in the distance and
he says, "Hartford?"
And the answer is, "Camelot."
[ Laughter ]
And it's-- But that fits into my
theory which I haven't expressed
but part of my theory has to do
with developments and technology,
and Mark Twain was
fascinated by technology.
He was the first guy, he
knew-- on a typewriter.
And his story is very
much about the-- about--
it's very much about
making readers think
about how different the technology
of the late 19th Century is
from the technology
of Arthurian England.
Because his hero goes back and he's
got all of these magic, you know,
he's got-- I forgot, you
know, does he have a--
>> Joe Palca: A flint, I think.
>> James Gleick: -- a flint.
He has gun powder.
He becomes basically
king in the world.
I mean, well, people--
>> Joe Palca: He was able to
predict the solar eclipse.
That was a big one.
>> James Gleick: Exactly.
So, yeah, it's part of the same--
even though he predates H.G. Wells
and it is a kind of time travel,
it's time travel by being bonked
on the head and maybe he wakes
up at the end of the book,
and the whole things was a dream.
>> Joe Palca: Right.
So, you said there is a theory.
Is the theory that
this notion was tied
to the technological developments
or maybe you could articulate
that a little bit more?
>> James Gleick: Yeah, theory might
be a little bit of an overstatement
but I know it's my overstatement.
But it-- I try to explore what it's
about and I think one of the things
that it's clearly about is
how suddenly technology was
changing rapidly.
And for most of human history,
technology developed very slowly.
And when technology was
developing slowly, you didn't--
it didn't occur to you to think,
"What's the world going to be
like for my grandchildren,"
because the world was going
to be same for your grandchildren.
But now, England had been
through the industrial revolution
and there were all these marvelous
things around and railroad skimming
across the landscape and telegraph
was dramatically changing the way
people lived.
And you could see, there was
an awareness that people had
that machines could
change the way you lived,
could really alter social
intercourse, communication,
financial life, you name it.
And-- So, as the 19th
Century was ending
and there was this great
calendar date coming,
the turn of the century, lots of
people were suddenly fantasizing
about what the future would
bring, and so there was H.G. Wells
and a young man, you know, young
writer struggling to make a living,
and it was a natural fantasy for
him even though he turned out not be
in the time machine
especially optimistic.
>> Joe Palca: Yeah.
So that's the kicking off
point, but the book goes
on to explore the consequences
of that quite a bit.
I mean, that's-- this sort of
the maybe you're making the point
that now that it's
part of our landscape,
we don't think about its origins.
But now that it's part of our
landscape, we think about it a lot
and it shows up in
popular culture a lot.
And it's certainly was showing up,
we were just talking before the
event started about science fiction,
and that's the staple of--
I mean, maybe there was no
science fiction before H.G. Wells,
I'm not sure, Jules
Verne, I can't remember.
>> James Gleick: It was Jules Verne.
There were stuff-- There was
the beginning of fantasizing
about space travel and Jules Verne
also had submarines, of course.
>> Joe Palca: But, I mean,
you seemed fascinated
with the inherent contradictions
and possibilities,
and possibilities that came up.
Why-- What's the interest
in speculating on that?
>> James Gleick: Yeah,
I mean, that's--
you're right, that's the real reason
for writing the book is it's not
why didn't they have it before
but what are we doing with it now.
And I do have a sense that-- Well,
first of all, you and I both,
we both read some science
fiction when we were kids.
And I remember thinking, most
of the science fictions I read had
nothing to do with time travel.
There was a lot of space travel.
When I was a teenage boy,
there were a lot of stories
about teenage boys
running often, you know,
getting into spaceships
and having adventures.
But occasionally, there
would be some kind
of time travel science fictions
and those were always the weirdest,
the most mind-twisting,
logical puzzles.
They really made-- They made
you thinking away they were the
most fun.
And so part of the
idea of my book is
to explore the way
this seems developed,
not just in science fiction
but also in literature
and the rest of the culture.
Now, I'm digressing a little
but, soon after H.G. Wells,
almost contemporaneously, Marcel
Proust was performing a kind
of time travel in "In Search of Lost
Time," and thinking about memory
and talking about time
in a way that's very--
that sounds very much like the way
science fiction writers now talk
about time.
And James Joyce played with time
and Virginia Woolf played with time.
And people started to play
with time as they do today,
as we all do in our fantasies and
in our interactions with the world
in various smart and
sophisticated ways.
And all of the stuff, I don't mean
to claim that either H.G. Wells
or science fiction writers
in general are leading us
but they're certainly if not
leading us, they're doing something
in parallel with the
rest of the culture,
and the whole culture has been for
this whole past century thinking
about time in more and more
complicated and interesting ways.
>> Joe Palca: Yeah.
And I was just thinking
as you were saying it.
One, it's probably doesn't
parse this clearly but I wonder
if science fiction writers, when
they write about time travel tend
to write about what's going forward
and literary people tend to write
about what's going backward?
>> James Gleick: Well,
that's interesting.
I mean, maybe we should-- let's have
a-- can we have a show of hands?
Here's a question.
You've got a time machine, you
got one trip, you are guaranteed
that you get to return safely,
and you can go into the past
or the future, how many people
are going to the future?
And how many people
are going to the past?
OK.
>> Joe Palca: Yeah.
>> James Gleick: That
looked about 50/50.
>> Joe Palca: Yeah.
>> James Gleick: Now,
I've heard it theorized,
I don't endorse this theory that--
and I don't have a new
judgment based on these hands.
Some people have suggested that
men like to go to the future,
and women like to go to the past.
I don't know.
And you're suggesting maybe
that the literary folk are
more past-oriented?
>> Joe Palca: Well, I mean,
I don't know if you can make
it generalizable that way
but the minute you start writing
about a future as a serious author,
you're called a science
fiction writer.
>> James Gleick: That's,
that's right.
That's true.
>> Joe Palca: And so,
even though some
of these science fiction
pieces are very literary
in the way they are written,
but I think also the conundrums
that you talked about in the book,
and I hope you'll describe a couple
of them, that occurred when you go
into the past are somehow
more delicious--
>> James Gleick: Right.
>> Joe Palca: -- because you
wind up-- I mean, that's when--
>> James Gleick: That's
where you get into trouble.
>> Joe Palca: That's where you get
into trouble which is, you know,
if you can go back and then
prevent Hitler, that's the classic
from being born, could
you prevent the Holocaust?
And the question is, is there--
is it possible to change
time or are we stuck with it?
And if we are stuck with it,
how can-- well, you explain?
>> James Gleick: Well, first,
you made a really interesting point
I think that for whatever reason,
we tend to label fiction writers
who write about the future
as science fiction writers and
genre writers, whereas if you write
about the past, that's more likely
to be accepted as literary fiction.
And this is argument about John
Rivers as literary fiction,
I have a feeling it
might be being played
out in other rooms at this festival.
Well, it goes on.
And personally, my own feeling
is some of the greatest,
most magnificent writers of our
time are writing about the future
and it's better not to draw
bright lines but I don't believe
in these categories myself.
It is-- You're right, going into
the past is where the paradoxes--
the logical paradoxes
begin, where the fun begins
because you can meet yourself.
And what if you meet yourself?
I mean, already, that's sort of
a paradox, what's going on there?
Are you-- Which one of them is you?
I mean, there is this great--
I discussed it in the book a little
bit, an early science fiction story
by Robert Heinlein, "By Your
Bootstraps" where that's the joke,
the hero keeps meeting himself
and it's only a couple of days.
And at first, he's a little slow to
catch on that this new guy coming
through the hole, in the air, in the
room is himself and then they get
into fights, and that then, there
are three of them and so on.
And it's a farce, you know?
And then-- But there's always
an arms race, you know,
in fiction because once that's
done then the next person has
to top that.
And pretty early on, you have
people wondering about what
if you kill an ancestor
and the canonical ancestor
for whatever reason
is the grandfather,
so it's called the
grandfather paradox.
And then you have people
actually having sex with people
and giving birth to themselves.
And then, there are-- very early,
there are transgender versions
of this so the people are
their own fathers and mothers.
This is, you know, long before
transgender studies became a
worthwhile subject, the science
fiction writers were there first.
And as far as I can tell,
completely judgment free.
>> Joe Palca: Yeah.
>> James Gleick: But weird things
happen and so weird that in all
of the time travel stories
and movies that you think of,
once they get into these paradoxes,
you sort of think there has
to be a trick, there's no-- if
you think about it too hard,
it can't really be working
because time travel isn't
really possible, is it?
[ Laughter ]
>> Joe Palca: Maybe we could
anyone show hands on that.
>> James Gleick: If you're-- Yes, if
you are visiting from the future--
[ Laughter ]
-- reveal yourself now?
>> Joe Palca: I guess we're
all visiting from the past
if you want to think about--
>> James Gleick: We're all
visiting from the past.
>> Joe Palca: I was hoping actually
and I guess you've already indicated
that there's no resolution here, but
after watching a movie like X-Men:
Days of Future Past or
whatever it's called or the--
even the Back for the Future
movies, my kids would get
into these heroic arguments
about, "That's not possible,"
"Yes, it is," "No, it's not."
I mean, is there a
logical right and wrong
to this conundrums going backwards?
Or you just-- you can
pick any outcome you
like because it's impossible?
>> James Gleick: I'm kind
of now I'm vacillating.
I couldn't answer that
question definitively.
I give you my opinion.
My opinion is time travel
is not really possible one.
I know that is a terrible
thing for me to be saying.
Probably, half of the people who are
about to buy my book
are now not going to.
[ Laughter ]
But it's also--
>> Joe Palca: I hope you sharpen
your arguments if you buy the book--
>> James Gleick: It's--
>> Joe Palca: -- because, you know,
you have to know what the
other side is thinking.
>> James Gleick: It's also
true that, it's also true
that when you talk to physicists,
it's quite possible to get
into a serious discussion
with physicists today
about the grandfather paradox.
And if not literally the possibility
of going back with a handgun
and popping the guy, the physics
equivalents of that, are there ways
in which there could be
loops in time, causal loops.
And if physicists aren't
quite willing to roll
that out then you have to ask
yourselves, who am I to roll it out,
you know, they're the experts.
And it's also-- A part of
that story, I feel strongly,
is that physicists and philosophers
are growing up and living
in the same culture
as the rest of us,
and they're reading
the same stories.
And if they are pondering
these paradoxes
and these logical difficulties from
the point of view of a specialized
and well-equipped kind of
science, all the better.
So, there isn't as-- I'm not
willing to give a definitive answer,
I'm willing to say,
any kid who is arguing
about it is thinking
along productive lines.
>> Joe Palca: Yeah.
Yeah. What is-- The other thing
that you bring up fairly early on
and I think it's very
thought-provoking is they talked
about the time as being the fourth
dimension where there is space
and then there is time, and then
you get into the whole question
of where there are spaces
and emergent property
of time which you bring up.
But the idea that we can't perceive
the fourth dimension because we're
in a three-dimensional
world is a little bit
like the book "Flatland," where--
>> James Gleick: Yeah.
>> Joe Palca: -- the people
in the plain couldn't--
on a plain surface couldn't imagine
if there was anything sticking up.
You talked about the possibility
of being able to create a world
as it were that could
see all those--
all four dimensions
at the same time.
Talk a little bit about that?
>> James Gleick: We're kind of
going back to the beginning again.
We're going back to H.G.
Wells, because in 1895,
H.G. Wells starts his
story in this way.
His, not as narrator, but his
hero who doesn't even have a name
in the book is called, the
Time Traveller, gathers his--
it's such an old fashion
way of writing.
He's in his house in London and
he gathers his friends around
and he says, "I've had a little
adventure and I'm going to tell you
about it but first, I have to
explain a few things to you,"
and he gives them a
lecture on science.
And the lecture begins by-- with
this notion of the fourth dimension.
He says, "I'm going to tell
you-- let's talk about geometry.
Everything they taught you about
geometry in school is wrong.
They taught you that there
are only three dimensions,
length, breadth, and height."
And his friends say,
"Well, yes, of course,
there are only three dimensions."
And he says, "No.
Think about it, isn't
duration also a dimension?"
And they go on like that.
And it's 1895, it's 10
years later that Einstein
and his teacher Minkowski put
forward the notion of space time
as a four-dimensional
continuum and explained to us
that it's extremely productive for
physicists to think of the universe
in terms of four dimensions
in which time is just
like the other three dimensions.
Mathematically, it's treated
the same way and that means
that mathematically speaking,
there's no difference
in the equations between
the past and the future.
And this is, you know,
pretty mind-boggling in 1905
and for the generation that
followed and to this day.
But what's going on?
Is H.G. Wells somehow
intuiting the new science
of relativity before Einstein?
I am not suggesting that
because H.G. Wells, as I said,
a young man really didn't--
he didn't know anything,
he didn't even study physics really.
He did have some background
in science
but it was mostly about geology.
Is it just a coincidence?
It can't be a coincidence.
I don't believe in that.
So, there was something in the air.
And one of the things
that was in the air,
you mentioned was "Flatland."
I don't know how many
of you know that book.
It's 1870s, 1880s, it's-- I
don't know if it was for kids,
but it's readable by kids
and it's a sort of fantasy
about two-dimensional creatures
trying to wrap their minds
around the idea of
a third dimension.
And we, as three-dimensional
creatures have the advantage
over them.
And so, the question is, could
there be a fourth spatial dimension
that is as difficult
for us to imagine
as the third dimension is for them.
Well, you know, we leap ahead more
than a hundred years and we know
that physicists are
very happy to talk
about not just the fourth dimension
of time but where necessary
or where it's useful, they'll
talk about five dimensions
or 12 dimensions, many dimensions.
And I think it's fair to say that
we're still in the same position
of not being able to visualize that.
I won't ask for hands, but not many
people can even visualize a fourth
spatial dimension.
You can almost fake yourself
into thinking you can
visualize whether I can.
But that's my limit, 12
dimensions, I don't know.
But no, again, there's been
a real productive explosion
of geometrical thinking
in real science.
And it was starting right at
this time that fantastic writers
like H.G. Wells were letting
their thinking explode,
I think for the same reasons.
>> Joe Palca: So, I-- my background,
my academic background
is in psychology.
So, naturally, I was drawn to
the distinction between real
or absolute time and perceived time.
And I wonder if you talk
a little bit about that.
And is time the same for you and
me and people on the other side
of the universe or is it mutable?
>> James Gleick: You
know, again, yes, no.
[ Laughter ]
Well, first of all, the difference--
we humans have understood
for approximately 400 years
that there's a difference
between psychological time
and what you could call real, and
actually maybe longer than that.
Even Shakespeare talks, Shakespeare
talks about how our sense
of time varies from
moment to moment depending
on our mood or what we're doing.
People certainly knew that.
And then it was Isaac Newton
who said, time is absolute
and let's put psychological
time aside.
I'm going to define time in
a mathematical way, time T,
I need it for my equations,
it is absolute,
it flows everywhere
equably and the same.
And he insisted based on no
particular evidence, I would say,
that it's the same
everywhere in the universe.
And let's just treat it that
way, as absolute and universal.
And fine, that worked really great
as everybody knows until Einstein.
And Einstein changed
that and discovered
that there are some slippage,
and maybe not as much
slippage as we tend to think.
I tend to feel-- and you don't have
to consider me an authority on this,
this could be a matter
of prejudice--
I tend to feel that Einstein
was himself very much supporting
Newton's, the main distinction
Newton was making which was
between psychological
time and real time.
We use the word real time
to mean something else now,
but Einstein too needed time
to be something abstract,
very precise, very mathematical.
The difference was there isn't just
one clock for the entire universe,
there are different
clocks all over the place.
And if you start to move
quickly, your clock is moving
at a different speed from
somebody who is not moving at all.
And so, weird things happen and
that immediately starts playing
into time travel, science fiction.
You know, I remember one of my
favorite stories when I was a kid.
Bet you read this one?
>> Joe Palca: Yeah.
>> James Gleick: What
was the name of the book
where they're twins, twins?
>> Joe Palca: Time--
yes, I know that one.
Time-- Robert Heinlein?
>> James Gleick: Yes.
So they are twins and one of them--
and they-- there is telepathy,
you have to believe in that too.
So they have a special
way of communicating.
And one of them goes off to
space and one of them stays home.
And the one who goes off to
space stays young while the one
who stays home ages quickly.
And that is all scientifically
correct according to Einstein.
>> Joe Palca: Yup.
Yes, I do know that book.
In fact, I'm a little
embarrassed to say
that I read it again
from time to time.
But I take some solace again,
from your book which I didn't know
about in the back of describing the
need to read a book more than once
in order to fully appreciate it
because when you read it the first
time, you're reading it linearly,
whereas to understand all its nuance
like when you look at a picture,
you don't have to look at it from
the one beginning to the end.
So the book is linear
in time but it's meant
to be treated as a
whole work of art.
>> James Gleick: Yes.
>> Joe Palca: And so as you
become more and more familiar
with it, new bits appear to you.
>> James Gleick: And
that's unquestionably true.
But in the book, it also says
something that I don't agree with.
I mean, he is wonderful
on the subject of time,
another great fiction writer who
really gets obsessed with time.
But he says, if I understand
him correctly that, therefore,
the only true way, the best way to
understand the book is to have it
in your mind all at once.
When you finally, let's say,
have the book memorized,
if that's possible, if
you know the entire book,
then you understand the book.
There are no more surprises.
And I don't think that's right.
That doesn't correspond to
my experience of reading.
First of all, I don't think
you can ever get to that point.
And if you did get to that point,
I think it would take away
essential elements of books,
of stories which are
anticipation, surprise,
not knowing what's coming next.
Being driven forward by the
desire to know what's coming next,
you still make connections
between what you discover
and what you already knew, and then
there's a kind of satisfaction.
But I think if you ever get to
the point where the whole book is
in your head all at once, it takes--
it kind of destroys
it as a work of art.
And it's kind of in the same way
that if you imagine the piece
of music, if you were the kind
of being who didn't listen
to music linearly, but could kind
of magically absorb it all at once,
wouldn't that destroy something
essential about the experience
because it's about time, because
time as its medium and its subject.
[ Laughter ]
>> Joe Palca: It's true.
I said I would take questions
from the floor if anybody would
like to come up and ask or
otherwise, I'm doing pretty well.
You have to come up to the
microphone so that we can hear you.
And here it comes.
It's a race.
I guess we'll start here.
>> My first comment is on
the memorization of a book
as you were just discussing.
I have had the opportunity to read
books, you know, 10 years ago.
I read a lot of science fiction.
I read a book 10 years ago, I read
it today, it's a different book.
It's not because the book's
changed, it's because I've changed.
So that's something about not--
you know, memorizing a
book doesn't lose anything.
Even if I knew all the words,
it's still not the same,
but I had a question about writing.
If you're writing about the
past and you were time traveling
into the past, you kind of know
why you're going into the past.
You'd like to have a conversation
with Abraham Lincoln or you would
like to see dinosaurs
or some writing
that says you have a
destination in mind.
If you're writing for the future,
you have to make the destination up.
So, how did you look
at writing time travel
when you're going forward
and backward?
I knew that those are two
different things and I'd
like your opinion on that.
>> James Gleick: Yeah.
There-- I think it's true that they
are fundamentally two different
things, you know.
There are two kinds of people
in the world, people who would
like to divide the world in half
and people who see it whole.
But you're right, there's
a very clear distinction
between time travel to the
future and the past, and yet,
they do have things in common.
And there are kinds of time travel
stories where people go both ways
where they've-- they try out
each of the possibilities.
The-- You know, if we're
starting at the beginning,
there was Mark Twain sending
his guy to medieval England.
In his case, it wasn't to enable
Mark Twain to tell us something new
that we didn't know
about medieval England.
But that later became
a big motivation
for time travel stories
about the past.
Time travel fiction-- Well,
there's "Sherman & Peabody,"
"Rocky and Bullwinkle."
I'm-- I take that very
seriously, you know,
it's an educational device
even though in the case
of "Sherman & Peabody,"
you remember,
it's Mr. Sherman and his pet--
>> Joe Palca: Dog.
>> James Gleick: That's a
dog and pet human Peabody.
Usually, the past they go to
is not historically accurate.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, I shouldn't go on and
on about this, but you're right.
Then H.G. Wells is
imagining the future
and he is inventing a
future that does not exist.
And you have-- Then, you watch
writers making the most profound
kind of choices.
And of course, the first one
is, is this a utopian future
where everybody is happy
and you have a moral lesson
about how great a society
could work?
Or is it a dystopian future
where you're expressing some kind
of terrible fear or
some kind of warning
like 1984 or "Brave New World".
And I think if we counted
them up, we would discover
that our great writers
preferred dystopian futures.
>> Sure, thank you.
>> Joe Palca: Thank
you for your question.
>> I'd like to ask a question
about the limitations of language.
But before I do, I'm struck by
one of the last things you talked
about before questions was listening
to music or experiencing music
and about the experience
of it all at once.
I believe Mozart indicated
at some point in his life
that he heard the notes
all together, all at once.
And I think that the problem and
the difficulty of that concept is
about the limitations of language.
You haven't talked about sort of
what we call the arrow of time.
But, of course, our language
is limited by talking
about going back and going forward.
And obviously, there are theories of
time that it's all happening at once
but even talking about
this happening
at once is a problem of language.
So, could you address
that issue of language?
>> James Gleick: Yeah.
That's a really, that's
a really good question
and it's something I'm very
interested in and try to deal
with here and there in the book.
It's impossible to
separate the way we think
about time from the words we use.
And it's-- so, it's interesting to
focus on that and to kind of try
to subtract things that are
linguistic accidents from reality.
As soon as you start talking about
time as a fourth dimension right
from the beginning,
you have to wonder
to what extent were people
influenced by words that we use
for space and time maybe just
because there aren't enough
words to go around, you know.
One thing is before another.
One thing is-- Well,
if you say after,
that's definitely a time
word, but if you say before,
that could be a time
or a space word.
And then, you discover problems,
you discover not problems,
you discover interesting quirks
where different languages
treat time quite differently.
And you have to recognize that
your own language is causing you
to be prejudice in various ways.
If I ask the people in this
room to point to the future,
I'm going to guess that almost
everybody would do something
like this point forward because,
we westerners especially
speaking English,
but most of other western
languages think the future is ahead
of us, it lies ahead.
But believe me when I tell you
that there are quite a few cultures
where people think it's just as
obvious, it is just as obvious
that the future is there.
That's the future because I
can't see it and this is the past
because I can see it pretty clearly.
That might be an oversimplification
of their reason.
But again, it has to do with words.
And in Mandarin, the
directionality of time tends
to be vertical, not horizontal.
They think of time being
above and below, the past
and the future, above and below.
I'm not a Mandarin speaker so
don't press me for details.
But these things are--
I could go on and on.
Do you spend time, you waste time,
do you pass the time, all when you--
you have to admit,
metaphors are not accurate.
>> Joe Palca: And speaking of time,
I'm used to working in studios,
I'm working-- where there is
like a zillion clocks
telling me how we're doing
but I haven't gotten very--
so, I'm looking to my boss.
That's what I was thinking--
to my watch.
>> James Gleick: I'm so sorry to the
people in line that I'm rumbling on.
>> Joe Palca: Yeah,
well, I think that, yeah.
It's--
>> James Gleick: So, one more?
Two more?
>> Joe Palca: One more, quick one.
Yes.
>> All right.
>> Joe Palca: All though quick
ones are not really happening.
>> OK. I'll try to make this fast.
I've loved your books in the
past, right, for one thing.
I'm a little on the fence about
this one because I don't know
where this book is going.
I don't know that much about
it because it's brand new.
Is this book about the
fantasy thoughts of time travel
or time travel as a real science?
Because time traveling in the
future, you know, right on, because,
you know, the faster you
go, I mean, the, you know,
the time does slow down, all right?
Or actually speed up a few
and slow down where we left.
Anyway, but time traveling in the
past just seems kind of ridiculous
because it's just, I mean,
it's just not practical.
But so, what is the book?
>> James Gleick: What's
my book about?
>> Yeah, exactly?
>> James Gleick: What a
great question to wrap up.
We haven't said what
the book is about?
>> Joe Palca: Right, right,
what's the book about?
>> James Gleick: The
book is about the idea
of time travel in our culture.
How it has developed,
how it enriches the way
we think about things.
But here is what the book is not
about, it's not about how to do it.
[ Laughter ]
I cannot-- I can't
really help you there.
And it's not so much about
any science of time travel
because as far as I am
concerned, there isn't a lot
of real science of time travel yet.
[ Laughter ]
>> Joe Palca: OK.
And now we have to run.
>> James Gleick: OK.
Thank you all so much.
>> Joe Palca: Thank
you all very much.
[ Applause ]
>> James Gleick: I'm
really happy to be here.
[ Inaudible Discussion
and Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.